and uh now with us is javier villalobos
the uh mccullen
uh texas mayor uh he has to deal with
all of this mayor very good to have you
um what seems to be accelerating again
mayor
uh it does as a matter of fact that's
why we had a
last week we had to do a temporary
facility uh actually right here in
mcallen because catholic charities was
it's done uh they have a capacity of
1200 and that was it
we had to take an emergency action
otherwise
we were going to have about 200 plus
possible
possibly positive uh immigrants released
into macau and we couldn't do that
so yes we did uh we built a couple of
tents the next day we moved them to
what you just saw in mission texas so we
have an issue now
we have a tent of thousands of people in
donna
14 miles from there you go to the west
now we have mission and then you go to
the south and we have on zaldua's
so we kind of do have a mess
and to put it mildly that when you hear
these spikes in covet cases among some
of these migrants i'm sure your
residents get concerned about that as
well right
no definitely as a matter of fact we
have they've gone from positivity rate
of about four or five percent to now
in excess of 15 percent and that's one
of the issues we have throughout the rio
de valley
it has been increasing too i we cannot
attribute it to the immigrants
we cannot but we are concerned and we're
trying to do whatever we can
to keep our residents safe
uh you need more personnel you're gonna
get any
neo we need everything as a matter of
fact that's why we filed a
disaster declaration because we cannot
we cannot be doing a federal job and
this is not our responsibility
we're just trying to keep our people
safe so uh we found a declaration
because we need funds either from the
state from the federal government
to do what they're not doing and that
kind of angers us because it's a little
uh a callous disregard to have the
border patrol
just drop off uh the immigrants in
downtown mcgowan
now we love our border patrol we know
it's not their fault
we know where the direction comes from
and that's where we place the blame
all right uh hang in there mayor you've
had your hands full you just got elected
and just got in
power and you've had that knee deep in
this stuff
mayor villalobos